that masked man is mike show
the reigning manager of the year in the
national league mixing and matching his
lineup trying to keep guys fresh
as daniel ponce de leon makes his third
start
and he has pointed out to all of us he
wants to go deeper in the game today
to out batter a eugenio suarez
desperately trying to get this top of
the order goal
deep drive left field how about that to
get it going
suarez two-nothing reds
right on cue thank you very much number
four
for suarez for the reds 25 years of age
already in his fourth major league
season right he tyler malloy
2-2 is a base head into center fought
off
beat the shift and a base hit for cold
war
[Applause]
doesn't strike out very often he'll
serve it into right
tries to put it in play and this time he
does into center field for a base head
just finds a way doesn't it that's it
you get the two strikes you fight some
stuff off
malley threw a couple of good pitches on
the outer half that yachty just end up
spoiling two outs and the runner at
first and here's bader
had a couple of hits last night
including a home run
and bader lifts a high fly ball into
center at the wall
it's gone it's a home run
harrison vader he's done it again
last night again today vader to straight
away
center a two-run shot and he ties it up
at 2-2 baseball isn't has it all
here's a ball served down the right
field line fairball that goes to the
corner
and goldsmith is on his way to a leadoff
double in the third
that was some nice baseballism right
there by paul goldsmith
the 1-1 pitch into center field that's a
base hit here comes goldsmith
he will score easily and the cardinals
have their first lead of the afternoon
yachty is
two for two two base hits to center
three
two cardinals the 60-game
sprint as akiyama with a hard-hit ball
into right field for a base hit
good way to start the fourth
line drive base hit left center field
that'll reach the gap and castiano's on
his way to second base
it's the sixth double of the season for
nick castellanos
and carpenter rips it fair down the
right field line he is thinking too
castianos will hold him to a single
hustling over there to the line and
holds him to a single
lead off base hit for carpenter who had
been over two
oh versatility is key especially it
doesn't play as much
currently now having the dh here how
about
three for three look at you this game's
easy isn't it
for some guys not supposed to be that
easy
there's nate jones against carpenter and
the o2 pitch
and that's hit down the right field line
at a base hit
carpenter thinking two out of the box
and diving in head first safely
matt carpenter two for four
with a single and now a double love the
hustle
big gap in left center field carpenter
your runner at third
trying to extend this lead the 1-2
pitch served into right and a base hit
for yada yada molina
it's a four-hit day he drives in
carpenter four to two cardinals for
hit day yeti dylan carlson
right now would be a good time for his
first ever cardinal home run
are you calling it go out on a limb and
carlson hits it out to deep right field
it's at the wolves gone
there it is first ever home run in the
big leagues
dylan carlson and he does it here at
busch stadium
all right dylan to me you could see as
if bats were becoming much better in
this game
and that's driven out to the gap in left
center
and those at bats are getting better and
better
ron rule double for harrison bader now
freddie galvez
double play could end it
ground ball goldsmith back to um
double play and the cardinals win it by
the final of six to two
they take three of four and an afternoon
in which dylan carlson picks up
his first ever big league homer and
yachty
has four hits six to the final